[Music]
but then the sun came out
and then a podcast turned on
and we had four boys in a podcast
welcome back guys
four boys and four windows four boys
four boys on the podcast
that's the new name of this podcast four
boys in a podcast
yes uh who's on the show today
you guys want to uh yeah go around hey
what's up i'm ren i'm here today
i'm
asmr experiences
yeah i'm known for being an all-around
decent fella matt
what about you yeah i'm just happy to be
here guys
we got asmr guy good guy and happy to be
here guy
and yeah yeah it's gonna be a good one
today perfect
um wow so um you guys have been
working on something special for the
last two weeks uh
yeah now what you wanna you wanna go
into some details on this i mean
what what is this we're releasing
something next weekend
right and so there's a lot to talk about
with this because it's not just the
piece itself
there's also another thing that's
sort of bigger that's beyond just this
single episode i think i know what
you're talking about but you're being so
vague that i'm a little worried i'm not
tracking you oh sorry
i'm talking about what you guys have
been working on all day and all week
okay
yeah yes it starts with a t
and ends with an acta cool reloads
tactical three loads everybody
tactical reloads is now coming
to corridor digital that's right uh we
recorded it way back
in the before times uh yeah
pre-quarantined pre-covet all that stuff
we recorded it in march
and then man we went through
trial and tribulation with the with the
stay at home thing
uh then we had to figure out you know we
had some pickup days that we had to film
with freddy
um then we had uh you know
extra shots that we wanted to get in
there to sort of smooth out action beats
and action moments and then
um for the last two weeks or so you guys
have just been
cranking on effects
kevin suzaki's been doing the sound
design it's looking really good
it it's definitely like one of the
nicest productions we've done in a long
time
at corridor yeah i saw the rough cut and
uh
the joke seemed to be working and
everything so that's always a good sign
when you when you get a rough cut
together and it's actually working like
that
keanu reeves is the best
[Laughter]
yeah no but seriously the jokes are
working and like there's
like character yeah and like other cool
things like
dialogue that seems to actually work in
cinematography that actually looks nice
like all the things like well here's the
thing like when you guys are watching
like
a movie or a tv show or something like
that at a certain point
even if it's not necessarily a good one
at a certain point you just kind of
slip into it right you just accept the
reality you're not looking at actors
you're looking at characters
and now you're just watching a show
right yeah but there's that
line you have to get over that hurdle as
a filmmaker where before that
you have to like you have to get past
the point where people aren't seeing the
actors and they're not seeing the camera
work or they're not seeing the set in
the location like
you know getting across that line can be
a little challenging
and yeah because peace like yeah with
all its cheese and it's campiness like
it's easy to end up pulling people out
but
it pulls you in like even myself like i
don't see me
acting i see my character when i'm
watching it that's
called gravitas nico graviton
yeah it's when you you get that sobriety
that that
that realism of the character regardless
of what they're playing
where you look at them and you're like
that's actually happening
that's not an actor right
sam is one of the most gravitas if i
must say
yeah i don't know if graceful is a word
but
that we can apply to sam but
he can he's got this certain uh you know
je ne sais quoi
when he gets into a role he he
definitely has some very funny moments
in there too
he's oh some of the best reactions in
the piece
dude he's like angry neck twitch yeah
like an angry neck twitch is just great
yeah so you're not so bad you're so much
of that neck
jake when it comes to acting you're not
so you know you're not so bad yourself
yeah sometimes i can nail it sometimes
i've looked back you know you know when
you
like you make so many videos you look
back at certain ones
uh and sometimes you watch them and
you're thinking oh my god why was i
doing that
but if no one else notices then you know
i guess i guess it doesn't matter but i
guess that's a good sign
you know it shows that you're like
improving because there's there's
there's old videos where
i can clearly see like why am i i'm over
acting so hard in this why am i
but yeah um yeah so uh
you know this is the third iteration not
only do we have
um nico and freddy we also got
matt best in it uh and uh we shot it in
the brcc warehouse which they had like
this giant
monitor setup that was kind of we didn't
expect to use it but
for one of the scenes you know they have
it's like i think it was like
five monitors across and four down
yeah so there's this giant bad guy wall
of monitors that
uh when we got there on the day we were
in the warehouse and you know we were
filming around it and we said oh hey
we'll just use that as the backdrop for
the bad guys because that that works
and then and then we didn't expect it to
work because you know
usually stuff like that doesn't work and
uh and then somebody casually asked um
hey does that thing turn on
and then they went and got somebody and
this guy came in
and he just he switches it on all of a
sudden and then all of a sudden we went
from having
you know it wasn't bad but it was like
generic bad guy and then all of a sudden
it was
super super bad guys
with this whole yeah the production
quality just took a big leap
yeah so that was nice that was
unexpected and then um
you know we pulled a few maneuvers i
think to like hide some of the
jankiness from some of the other scenes
you know like with the whole like
i was really concerned about the um the
uh
gun range in the hallway thing but i saw
the footage and
most people won't notice it it's
definitely like once again it's like it
doesn't distract you per se it doesn't
look expensive like it looks cheap
yeah but it doesn't like it doesn't make
you go like i'm just watching some dudes
trying to make a video
baby's baby's first video yeah
yeah yeah i think really ren really
wants us to acknowledge what's happening
right now
but i'm not gonna give it to you i'm not
gonna let you win
where did that background come from ren
this background
yeah uh jamaica why is it backwards no
no no this is from a show and i forget
the name of it but it's an amazing show
it's a cartoon right yeah everything is
it called isn't everything amazing
i forget i don't remember where the name
of the show
but there's this other one from like the
same maker who's like
it's it's a very futurologist type short
film
and with that sort of art style this
sort of art style anyway wait is that
the people that made bojack
horseman or is that a different okay for
those of you who are listening only ren
has some weird background with just
some some character like line-drawn
characters
but anyways so anyway the the the
tactical reload series
i think at first you know we didn't know
if it was a series or not and then
the first one took off and we said oh
hey maybe we should make another one of
these
and then you know nico i i'll say you
you went out on a limb with the story
plot line on the
on the second one i didn't i was very
concerned that that's not what people
wanted to see
but sure enough uh you know that one did
great and now
and then we went we went full on into
the third one uh
extended the storylines a little bit and
now
on the website we are announcing
tactical the show
yeah that's right more episodes if it
gets if it gets green lit it's
up to the uh the users to decide if they
want to green light that or not of
course
yeah but uh you know just to pull that
up here
let's let's pull that up um
so green light it guys if you go to
collect it if you go to quarter digital
which is anyone can see this page uh
so far 5 000 points have been put into
tactical so yeah oh yeah
you know it's probably not gonna happen
this year uh if it does you know
great that would be that'd be great but
um i'm excited for that and so
the mission now on uh well tomorrow i
guess
is uh you guys have to go show this to
freddy
right yeah now yeah see here's the thing
okay
because throughout all these episodes
freddy has been basically the best
friend ever in the sense that he's just
kind of shown up and shot them with us
and participated with us
and like gone along on this like hey
freddie can you do
three days of filming uh for us for this
video that
and he's every time he's shown up so now
now we have to show him the best
hopefully the best one yet and then get
him excited
for tactical the show there's a couple
things like at play here
by the way so like you know the first
one is kind of a viral video concept but
it has some story and some characters
the second one yeah you're right i i put
in a lot more story it's like half story
half action whereas the other one was
like
80 and 90 action in like 10 or 20 story
yeah
but the thing is if the third one comes
out and the third one does well
we effectively have three episodes of a
series with you know
and the first two each have like 15 or
something like that million
each like three episodes in a row with
story and characters and all them having
maybe over 10 million if you know the
third one pops like
that's you're looking at potential
actual television series right there
because you know those numbers are
television numbers yeah
and if you've done it once cool if
you've done it twice maybe you got
something if you've done it three times
well you're definitely making like
something's working right each one's not
an accident anymore yeah
you didn't just happen to go viral now
we gotta take you go go ahead
well it's gonna stay easy now it's a
cool potential to have
and you know in the olden days we would
take that and we'd go and we'd try to
pitch it right like all right here's our
pilot here's our scripts here's some
future episodes we can do
but now we don't have to do that now we
can be like look
audience if you want to see more of
these we can make the show for real and
the the green light system like the
amount of points we put up is
that's approaching you know it's not a
huge budget but it's enough of a budget
to make this happen
yeah and yeah it's just it's it's it's
interesting and that you know that's
kind of the other
challenge here is that when you when you
want to make more of these things it
can't all just be action at some point
you have to start telling a story
and so you know there is that challenge
of like well
can can one write a story that's
compelling in this world how do you do
that
and honestly like the more pieces i've
made the more i've realized like i have
a ton to learn when it comes to writing
um you know i can write basic functional
stories but anything that has like
nuance or like
a twist on like how it's record you know
made or something like that like
i can't defy conventions or anything yet
like i i'm a
basic baby script writer at this point
but the thing i realize with tactical
and almost with like all the stories i
do right now is like
it's okay to work in convention as long
as like the
dressing that you're putting on it is
special you know it's okay to tell
conventional story
when you have like people that are
literally juggling guns
as like a part of this world that you
know and that's where the story comes
from
right and and like all the jank that
surrounds it
that all kind of melts away the more
direct you get with your story beats
like when you don't sit there and like
if you if you try to milk the acting for
a shot or like hold a long reaction like
you'll start to lose people but if
you're just like and facts facts facts
facts facts and just hitting people
facts about the world the characters in
the situation and something like you
know they have to start building this
internal narrative
yeah like all that [ __ ] kind of melts
away pretty quickly
as long as you're hitting that story
directly clearly and
you know not trying to you know punch
outside your weight class too hard
right no totally yeah that's that's a
common
mistake that that i think everyone makes
when they're writing anything narrative
however long it is there's there's
there's always a tendency
when you're starting out to uh
just oh well this is this is funny so i
want to keep it in or
even though it's not in any way related
to
the actual where the rubber meets the
road for the characters where they
actually go forward and there's
in their story um and so
yeah right writing that out is you know
anytime i see that when i'm watching
anything narrative it's an immediate you
know
you can immediately get out of it when
you're
yeah it's easy to fall in love with your
characters and want to be like oh what
if i just like
had this character do this funny
one-liner you know and like at some
point
you can do that but not in the first two
minutes of your youtube video like
how long you have to watch a movie
before the movie gets to have its
characters like have us
you know have a [ __ ] singer just do
whatever yeah you know they don't do
that in the first 30 seconds
they do that like 30 minutes in you know
since i mean that's
that's the fourth tactical episode if
you look at it that way yeah
yeah yeah so then you're just doing
sticks then you're just writing sticks
you know that's just not exactly maybe
we should do a video of that
just to defy everything i just said just
a video
just a video of sticks where you're not
you're not quite clear what's happening
i guess that's the second iteration of
there's no time to explain
rend i oh yeah we need to i was thinking
about we should bring that back
man that would be good
we should there's it should be called
like there's still no time to explain
there's still yeah yeah there's still no
time to explain
uh so uh rand matt you guys were heavy
in the effects on this one
um yeah what was the what was the
hardest
slash most challenging thing so far that
you said
i feel like you and clint had some of
the more challenging shots
for sure i i well okay
there's different kinds of challenging
here right exactly
your challenge is the fact that you have
so many green screen shots
and trying to maintain a very
certain like uh level of quality and
consistency
amongst the dozens of shots that you
worked on for green screening
uh for me it's a lot of just challenging
tracks where there's like there's a shot
where niko's like flipping over
uh matt or this other mat this this dude
in the video
uh nico's flipping over them and like i
tracked in like this little couch hit on
the back of
like this bullet goes whizzing by and
then hits his jacket
yeah but it's a very it looks really
good there's not really much track there
it's like the gun goes over the entire
shot at some point
so all my hand motions are wigging out
right now uh
i'm gonna turn off my video real quick
well stop flying around new york city
dude
yeah so uh a lot of stuff like that but
clint and i are currently kind of going
back and forth because i've been adding
like these distorted like
matrix bullet trails and i like them a
lot and i want to like they look
awesome dude and every single note from
clint so far has been dial it back
like a lot and i'm like oh but i want
more distortion i want all of the
distortion he's like no
so guess what ren those shots are
approved you don't have to touch them
yeah at least the bullets flying by like
matt's vest i thought those shots were
great sweet and like
you know what maybe they could be dialed
around a little bit but also we need to
be done with the effects in like a day
yeah i have i have a large list of uh
shots that i still have to fix here um
so i've got a lot of work left to do
um even through all all tomorrow yeah so
that's what i'm cranking on
and i don't mind like i know it's not
super consistent but i also don't really
mind the over-the-top nature of
like you know of some of those effects
well so what i was going for i was just
referencing the very first
tactical reloads where i remember i did
the bullet trails for that with like the
really distorted like matrix lines you
know
and i remember those being like really
over the top and so i was like i'm gonna
make them over the top like that because
there's precedent for it within the
series
and so that's what i started doing and
then clint was like dial it back i was
like
so i went back and i looked at it i was
like actually they are a lot more
subdued than i remember them being
in that first video well there was like
there's that one shot where the two
bullets
hit the shoot the handcuffs off of the
girl
that's that was what i was thinking of
okay but like the distortion there is a
little bit different
a little not quite as good there are
better effects
to use now like red giants uh like
chrome
chroma displacement okay is like it's a
really good uh
displacement distortion type effect
now um nico do you have any concerns at
all that uh
some of the character elements from
between you and freddie might carry into
the real world
like if we go and see him tomorrow and
he's
not impressed by tactical reloads and
then
you know he like leaves the partnership
and then you have to go out and
you have to bring him back in and say
come on freddy we gotta do this show man
i mean that's that's always a risk but
you know what my friendship is built on
confidence and trust
and i'm confident that freddie will love
it
and we've maintained an atmosphere of
fun like endeavor endeavoring like
you know energetic like artistically
honest
filmmaking when we make this so you know
now granted the man's busy i can't take
so much of his time unless we start like
incorporating him into the productions
like he said he's been like the greatest
friend ever when it comes to
participating with this stuff
yeah and like now it's time for us to
like we're gonna keep making tactical
real just time to like make this a
little bit more official between us
you know yeah totally hopefully we'll
get a chance to do that
well honestly i think it's turning out
really solid and
you know once again it kind of comes
down to like what happens with the
website and with everybody you know
that's on it like if people feel like
tactical reloads is worth their you know
producer points
um you know like freddie's ready to come
on board and
join us and like help us write some of
this we'll have a bunch of time to
rehearse and like plan cool stunts and
like
like you know all those stuntmen react
episodes we've been filming like
those are all people we know now that we
have connections with like we could be
doing some crazy stuff
as long as we have an excuse to go out
there and make it
yeah and you know we can't entirely
entirely rely on people for favors like
you could ask people for favors when
you're like a kid in college or you're
making your first film
yeah but once you're like 800 films deep
it's like your 900th video on youtube
you're like hey i was wondering if i
could ask you for a favor they're like
uh
haven't you haven't you made a career
out of this for the last 10
10 years yeah a career out of favor for
a month
asking favors of people yeah yeah
it's an art form yeah yeah
well to talk about a few other things uh
that have happened on the site
um so functional filmmaking
was greenlit uh was it this
oh yeah now we gotta do that uh
we're gonna execute this thing yes so um
so that
was greenland you should talk about our
lessons like what are we gonna teach
people give a little preview in this
podcast you know yes i i wanna do that i
just wanna point out a couple
things before we do uh so
ren i don't know if you've looked
functional filmmaking has been greenlit
son of a dungeon 430 points away
right that's crazy so uh
we've got some uh we've got some work to
do
boys to make this happen and i i do want
to talk about functional filmmaking
ideas
uh one thing i'm concerned about is that
uh it's it's one of those ones where
you're like oh yeah functional
filmmaking we will teach some you know
some abridged courses
uh on our method of thinking
when approaching when approaching
filmmaking
i think this is going to be a little bit
harder than we than we think
because because what we have to do is we
have to boil down
the like philosophical essence of
of how you approach a filmmaking problem
and then attach it and then attach it to
an actual example that we can use as
this sort of
through line for each class
so we have a few um you know
we we've got uh well we've got nico and
ren here and you guys have already kind
of identified two classes
so i mean do you guys want to tell the
audience a bit like about
just what those are and then at least
what maybe the initial approach is
yeah um randy you want to kick things
off
sure all right i have no idea what we're
gonna do
oh come on that's not true
i've already made all my knowledge
videos i have no more knowledge
i have done no more knowledge to give uh
yeah so the general idea is i'm gonna
kind of do whatever the functional
filmmaking episode is around how i make
these
uh science videos that i make
and i don't exactly know what that
should be yet
i haven't really put in a lot of effort
into
thinking about exactly like the
structure or like
specific examples and breakdowns to
include within that
uh i am currently not right now but like
uh
i have been working a little bit on a
new science video hopefully coming out
at some point uh that maybe will be a
good
excuse to kind of do a follow along with
so it's like i uh
i'll have like all the previous videos
that i've made that i can do examples
from and breakdowns
for uh giving context behind certain
decisions
that i chose to highlight within the
video and decisions
because usually the hardest thing is
figuring out what not to include in a
video
because i want to include everything and
it's always like well if you did that
it'd be an hour long and it would take
four and a half years to make
so it's always like trying to figure out
okay how can you best streamline this
process so
uh the video i'm working on next uh
hopefully i mean i've got so many
different video ideas and they're not
necessarily the science videos
but how many solar panels could power
the world
now on the surface that seems like a
fairly direct question it's like okay
how much energy does humanity consume
how many panels can output that much
energy done
and it's like the more i dove into that
the more complicated it got like there's
different kinds of energy like
electricity is only like
a fifth of the energy that earth
consumes or humanity
society consumes uh but it's the most
efficient form of energy
uh most energy is in the form of heat so
like
heat and uh transportation so like
gasoline and stuff like that
diesel etc uh that's yeah so
i've been tr it's been really hard to
kind of figure out how to
narrow down all of these ideas and
concepts through research and doing math
and what not into something
that makes for a good video easily
isn't the most immediate one the
electricity
because the most immediate what the like
the most immediate
uh example to create the visuals from
like because you think about it you know
when you think about a solar panel
you don't think about a solar panel
making your car go
necessarily even though that is a thing
that solar panels solar panels now do
you you think about a solar panel like
oh well it you know it goes to the
electricity and that goes to buildings
and homes and things like that yeah yeah
so is there a way that you can like
you know focus it on to just like
buildings or something that's my i've
i've get i'm getting close but the short
answer is that like if i if i was to do
just like the electricity
section that's a cop-out you know like
like what would it take so that earth
was
100 based off of renewable energy but
that would require
some pretty heavy changes in society
beyond just like
getting rid of coal stations and putting
up solar panels instead like
right it's the whole point of tesla
trying to accelerate uh
sustainable transport you know uh and
but
the more electric cars are on the road
the more electricity demand there is and
so like all projections for how much
energy we'll be using in the future is
going up as far as electricity is
concerned
yeah yeah um i did figure out
exactly how many solar panels would be
needed to power my car
to go so i have a tesla model three and
it i get around 250 miles
per sorry 250 watt hours per mile so
about
four miles for every kilowatt hour of
energy and i
but i also so wait hold on how many
do you want to reveal how many oh it's a
lot you know because everyone thinks
like oh
if you just put solar panels on your car
it can just go forever right and the
answer is that like
for my car to have enough solar panels
uh
attached to it to be able to sustain the
engine running at 60 miles an hour just
down the road
it would be like five
semi truck trailers completely covered
in solar panels just
towing behind my car which of course
also adds in
extra weight and wind resistance which
increases the energy
uh needed so now you need another five
trucks just to power the power
yeah it's a compounding effect and so
yeah yeah and so it's like
the idea there is that it takes a lot of
energy to make a car move or to even
charge it at a decent rate if you put if
if you were to cover like the entirety
of my car and solar panels
like after a full day of charging i'd
get maybe like four miles
of range added wow so it's like it's
great if it's the post apocalypse and
you've gotten like an entire summer to
go across the state of nevada because
that's how long it's going to take you
but uh the so that's everyone's always
thinking oh you can just put solar
panels on a car and it'll go and that's
not true
but the other side of that the flip side
is that everyone thinks that you have to
cover like the entire
world in solar panels to have enough
energy to power the whole planet and
that's also
wrong you don't need that many uh to
power america you just need like a 100
by 100 mile
uh square and for the whole world it
comes out to around the square footage
of spain
so if you had like a block of of solar
panels
size of spain it is it is yeah yeah yeah
so most of that but if you if you're to
total up all of the
uh land covered in buildings that have
right
roofs it's a lot more than that yeah
it's way more than that
way more than that and so yeah it's uh
it's the whole purpose of all my like
science videos is trying to recognize
something that is easily understood
or no it's recognizing something that is
easy to
understand but is not well understood
and that's kind of like the thread go
that goes through every single one of my
videos whether it's like how big our
star wars ships
to yeah an easiest way to demonstrate
something like that is to show an image
you know you get
it's a very efficient form of
communication a thousand words for every
image right
so i have two questions about that first
question is do you find yourself
using uh
like the proper application of
mathematics and engineering principles
like when you're solving these
riddles these scripts or sure i mean
i am rarely rarely using advanced math
usually my math is like
just algebra like most of engineering
like
you have to take like high level math
classes like you have to take like
freaking differential equations linear
algebra vector calculus
and then most of engineering is
basically just advanced algebra
okay now what what sort of
so if you just take your example not
that you haven't i know you haven't
boiled down all the math on this yet but
you talk about that hundred by hundred
block of solar panels for america right
so
what would we need to do to
get that to actually have it be
practical like what what what would it
be like beyond
comprehension or no no no it's these are
all doable problems but they're all
extremely challenging because the
infrastructure isn't in place you know
it's like it's one thing to have like a
giant solar farm
that's creating all this electricity but
then you got to transport that long
distances which requires transformers to
get up to really high voltages to go
long distances
or like a smart grid that's able to like
pull from a bunch of different solar
panels all at once to
you know because right now there's
there's every evening
everyone uses a lot more electricity
than they do throughout the rest of the
day so it's really hard to accommodate
for that so there are what
are called peaker plants which are
basically gas powered uh natural gas
powered plants that they fire up in the
afternoon
just to supply any extra energy that's
needed on a moment's notice but if you
have a smart grid in place you don't
need any of those power plants
because it's all just like everyone's
talking to each other there's
it also goes hand in hand with like
battery storage systems because like
it's great if you could generate that
energy but if it doesn't go anywhere
it's just wasted
yeah and like the more i've like
researched into is into this
like the bigger and bigger the concept
gets and the harder it is to wrangle
what it is i want to say yeah down to
something into like a you know a four
minute video
totally uh how much money are these guys
making
if you if you're talking about like a an
energy industry where they have
plants that are literally just there and
there's somebody
there's a group of people whose job it
is to just fire that thing up every day
and make sure that it's running so that
all the idiots like like me
can just come home and like turn on the
lights and be like oh yeah the lights
i don't even think about them i just
turn them on they just work i don't know
uh like they must be that's a critical
industry obviously
the people that run these energy
companies i mean
they're obvious they've got to be for
profit right because otherwise why would
you do it
yeah yeah i mean it's usually i mean pg
e i think is a private company
you know like yeah they have to be
running at some sort of profit level
even if all of their uh stations are
starting to break down and cause
wildfires but
i'm just saying like from uh from uh
from the mentality of like okay who
who's gonna build a solar field that big
like you know yeah
you know there's a couple different ways
you could do that like obviously
yeah it's like you know the there's grid
scale
uh energy markets like there is a
marketplace for
like a ton of energy and there's always
demand for it because and that's a very
very consistent thing is demand for
electricity right and
and so uh it does fluctuate and that's
that's where the challenge lies is
because like all of a sudden if the
demand like fluctuates up
you have to like figure out how to meet
that demand um
and and and things like the temperature
outside can affect the efficiency of
power plants and that's why you start
seeing a lot of rolling blackouts in
places like southern california when it
gets really hot out because it changes
the
quality of air and the humidity of the
air and so that when you're trying to
actually burn something you're getting a
lot less efficiency
out of those turbines and so you end up
with a lot less power output
than these peaker plants which are
supposed to like you know provide all
this power and they can't so then
they're having to shut down certain
neighborhoods of the city
like all right for an hour you don't get
power sorry but that's just because
that's all we can do
no totally um it's it's a super vexing
and uh evolving problem it's it's not
like it's ever
the thing is you don't you can't
effectively like just come up with a
solution and then sort of just like put
it in a box because
not only is demand changing but also the
nature of energy itself
is something that's if just if energy is
just left
alone like like you said it'll just be
wasted so not only do you have to figure
out
like how to meet demand you also have to
figure out how to
keep and store it so that you can you
can
use it later when possible like right
now the biggest
uh i guess industry changing technology
that's really
starting to roll out is the idea of grid
scale battery storage you know tesla's
been really pushing this they made this
giant i want to say like one or two
hundred megawatt hour
energy storage plant in australia and
within like a year or two it already
started it already like recovered all of
its costs
in just in terms of like the money it
was making uh
selling energy when it was needed yeah
and because it's all electrical and
battery it's like it's able to flip
uh and be able to put full output on
like literally like a
flip of a switch that's not controlled
by people it's just like it whenever
it's needed it's suddenly you know
pouring out energy
uh but people always think of like
batteries as like the batteries you see
in like your tv remote or like a
lithium-ion battery
but like there's all kinds of different
forms of energy storage there's that
giant power plant between here in vegas
you know with all the mirrors reflecting
up to it yeah
that thing that shines so bright in the
middle is literally a thermal battery
it's a battery in the form of heat
because it's a giant pool
of molten salt and it's molten salt
because it has good thermal
characteristics of
of keeping that heat yeah and they just
run water through these pipes that go
through and it boils the water
which turns into it's very basically a
very fancy steam in
engine most power plants are in a way
yeah i mean that that's basically all
they are they're just fancy uh
you know coal plants but i thought we
were more evolved than that
you're telling me we're just still
powered by steve yeah he's also
steampunk at the end of the day steam is
good at doing work
hey do you know which is the most
efficient form
of reusable energy like which one
harnesses
the most power probably ocean tide i
would imagine
oh maybe on what where it is i guess
um geothermal answer all of our
questions
like if you set up enough uh like tide
harnessing energy things you'll stop all
the tides from moving
we did that we did that equation in in
college
and everyone got it wrong and our
professor got pissed uh he was like
you are gonna go do it again and do it
right this time we're like oh oh okay
uh yeah anyway um wow so and geothermal
like
the easiest way in the most sustainable
way is just from the sun because it's
always putting out energy it never
fluctuates weather permitting obviously
uh wind
sometimes it's not windy geothermal is
usually pretty consistent but like the
uh process of getting that heat is is a
challenging one and a hard one
uh nuclear is actually pretty solid but
everyone is afraid of nuclear
um and and for the amount of like space
you have to put around
like the no man's zone around a nuclear
power plant
yeah if you were to just fill all of
that with solar panels instead
you would end up with a fairly similar
power output
from solar than you would from nuclear
assuming of course you're in a climate
that supports solar yeah but like
germany for instance has a ton of solar
in there it's europe
like they have tons of clouds year round
england same same way they have tons of
solar there and it's it's working well
they have a bunch of them in minnesota
yeah
i'm dubious about that it feels like a
good way to not get energy
no it is a good way though they will be
doing it if it wasn't working though
clouds can cut down on energy on on
solar panels but like
it's not a huge factor uh
especially uh some of the technology
coming out right now is starting to try
to harness uh infrared energy a little
bit better than it currently does
which means clouds aren't even a factor
at all because infrared just goes
straight through clouds
oh really oh oh interesting and see
that's why you can still get sunburned
on a cloudy day
there's a whole world out there you know
yeah that's that future steam
that's that future second dude i can't
wait for future steam
that infrared steam yeah oh man
i'm gonna come home and turn on my
lights and go oh man you see that
you see that future steam steam infrared
steam that's what's that's there's power
in it
yeah it looks like lasers we have now
gotten on to this topic talking about
you know energy and whatnot and i
trust me i'm down to talk about this for
a long time
but this all started with you asking me
about what my functional filmmaking
episode's going to be
i think the whole conversation we just
went through
uh is a is a perfect representation
of what we're dealing with with
functional filmmaking
because you just go on tangents all day
well we have to we have to boil this
stuff down
like we have yeah we got to steam it up
boys
we gotta send it through the internets
and and on to the lights of the computer
monitors
yeah and phone screens uh they're
certainly like the question of like
i mean the format is important but also
the structure
right so like how are we structuring
each episode is it like a class where
like
one person teaches a couple of episodes
and that's a class
and then there's multiple people
teaching different classes yes
or how they're skipping these who's
editing them so
we so couple a lot of questions let me
answer let me answer them
uh first thing uh yeah so we're
we're gonna do classes which is you know
on the on the actual
quarter digital.com green light page uh
you can see there's there's four classes
that we've sort of
proposed at the moment we want to do
probably six to eight
now each one of those classes is gonna
have
numerous episodes within it like
effectively it'll be
you know some somewhere between like
hopefully 30 and 45 minutes of
information
but each one will will be sort of it'll
be bite-sized so you know maybe five
minutes here maybe 15 minutes here on
this
on this part of it each one of which is
is like
lessons in a in a in building blocks
that
that sort of take you through now the
challenge is like
like ren was kind of going into we need
to identify uh
the philosophy behind the approach which
for ren is
making concepts that are uh not easily
understood
easy to understand uh when you could
present
concise facts and then talking taking an
example
showing why just like we talked about
the
the to get the facts concise can be
often
the challenge in it of in and of itself
and so
we need to come up with a lesson a
lesson plan that
illustrates that and so you you may even
want to do it by like
using the solar panels idea as
the as the through line and so you know
maybe it's easier to look at it with
hindsight once you've
gone through the process but for for
example
we could do that we could put that video
out and then you could use that as the
example for functional filmmaking to
show
how you got through each layer of the
problem
uh as you went through it right uh so
that'd be one
uh the the the other one nico's one is
uh how to master any camera
so uh you know i imagine that's
god that that probably has a few less
steps maybe than ren's but
uh i i don't know nico do you have
thoughts
that's also how to master any camera is
a very broad thing too because i need to
basically
condense all the knowledge across all
photography devices and
boil it down to these essential
fundamental pieces of knowledge
that can apply to any system but
everything everything from a gopro to a
red
camera you do want to show how
that actually works across cameras
though
yes you know so it was even once you
identify the core
tenets of like say it's light camera
tech and color science or whatever
like you know you want to show
specifically like okay
here's the same step here's the same
three or four step process let's do it
to this camera
okay what kind of image do we get and
then maybe compare those together
so that one that one's a little bit
easier at the onset but like
you know clint's gonna encounter the
same problem with his uh
how to make any image photo realistic
idea
because yeah that's something that he's
very passionate about
but i i don't i don't know how to
his whole thing is okay you've got
objects in the real world
how do you capture the the texture
and the aesthetic of that and then apply
it in in any 3d program what are the
what are the fundamentals
i think he's going to have an easy time
you think he's completely honest i think
he's going to
be totally fine doing that entire
episode because he's been practicing
every single weekend
uh you know doing his his like three
hour live stream uh
i haven't seen that yeah and it's like
you know he's like
he's got he's just been practicing uh
not just doing the effects themselves
but communicating
why and how okay why is important and
that's and
so like yeah it'll be it'll take some
effort from him to boil all of it down
to like a video uh that kind of
can be for anyone rather than just a fx
artist but i'm i'm fairly confident
he'll be able to pull it off and do it
well
so then the next question comes down to
okay who edits it right like who
who puts the whole show together now
now this is this isn't something that we
finalized
okay so don't go over and start
commenting this is more to the listeners
start commenting that hey we're so
excited about this this is something
we've had a preliminary conversation
we're we're both interested in pursuing
both functional filmmaking and son of a
dungeon
prospectively looking at carmichael
to the nicest dude return the nicest
dude
returning have you talked to him yet yes
i've
talked to him okay i
you haven't talked to him about it yet
and i was that was monday
yeah and i talked to him i talked to him
uh
yesterday and we had a long conversation
he's he's interested but we have a ton
of details to work out
uh so i in no way am saying that
carmichael is going to create these
shows
all i'm saying is we've had a
conversation about it
and we're both interested and we both
think that it would be awesome
if we could make both of these happen
together so that's good
uh you just threw pressure out into the
universe jake
you just did it you have now laid a jinx
i know your court carmichael your move
carmichael
uh no so i mean but the thing is this is
what i was explaining to him on the
phone like
no one is better suited
to handle both of these shows i don't
think yeah
so you know for everyone that's
subscribed to the site i mean
you know maybe once we maybe you know
maybe just say like
maybe in the comments like hey you know
who would be great carmichael would be
great for this
and then you know maybe he'll see those
and just be like oh man
you know i got to do it no
but seriously with with his
understanding of our workflow
his job for for three years
being literally to understand the
philosophy behind our workflow
and and and make videos out of it it was
a long longer than three
yeah well we did the vlog for like three
and then he was with us for
two before anyway yeah it was a lot
longer uh
but that was literally his job and then
you know son of a dungeon like
we we had we had our call and he was
immediately
on it with just ideas that he's already
had
for because you know he has his own dnd
show and so
yeah with us it's just like hey here
here are a bunch of other ideas that i
have
uh that would be super fun to do um and
here's all the lessons i've already
learned from trying to
do it myself in x y and z methods
and so yeah i think it could be i think
it could be huge but i
do think this is going to take longer
for both of these than we
will we would like but it depends like
what like caliber of quality you want
them to be at because we can do all of
them
all of the functional filmmaking
episodes we can kick them out every
single one in a week
well yeah but we can doesn't mean we
should
yeah we will we shouldn't like what you
know
let me know actually let me know if
you're subscribed to the site
whether no no no no no i'm washing this
right now
i'm i'll let you know look i no but i
just want to see
what i just want to see what the
comments are i think these shows right
now are an opportunity to
as as we continue to make videos and new
people continue to discover them and we
say like hey check out
quarterdigital.com
by having a library of quality videos
that are
unparalleled elsewhere that's you know
that's even more reason for
people to come over visit sign up and
watch well that would be my assumption
as well and
if i was paying for it that would be my
assumption in terms of what i would want
but yeah uh you know like that's the
thing about the site it's
in a way it's not really up to us nico
it's kind of up to what people are
paying for
so yeah there's a given there's a give
and take there they got the peepees you
know what can you do
i can't believe we went with that wow
that's producer points producers
guys producer points it's producer
points guys i
i don't know what you want me to say
it's pretty
what what was the alternative well yeah
uh but anyways so like i think
quality over quantity here certainly but
timing
is a is a factor we do want to get that
get the stuff out as soon as we can
so there's there's a clear one-to-one
relationship between things getting
greenlit and things getting released
but you know we might be looking at end
of the year for some of this stuff
yeah it's like i think we well yeah
maybe i think we could get
it comes down to functional filmmaking
like i think the question with that is
because the nice thing is everybody's
writing their own episode it's not like
one of us has to write like six episodes
of functional filmmaking that's true
like i could write my own episode in a
week you know
um now i don't know if everybody else
can get the same you know issue and i
think in a way like with them
potentially being a little bit longer
it almost make it easier to be able to
you know write what you know
and not try to like have to boil it down
to like the perfect click bait
you know hook for youtube but like just
be like here's knowledge here's
knowledge
here's knowledge raw and
unsteamed only only the finest steams
nico
some raw some hot steamed knowledge um
anyways uh yeah you know it i just i
think we can turn it out
especially if you know carmichael's on
board helping edit these things
um yeah i just i think there's gonna be
great classes i can't wait to like see
what ren comes up with i can't wait to
see
nick's approach to like turning anything
into a story
that one honestly nick's one i think
will probably be more valuable than
any of our others combined to be
completely honest
we'll just be giving that to other
people as they join corridor yeah
here's your training video made by nick
watch these
watch these four episodes yeah yep
yeah absolutely dude the corridor
training manual maybe that's what we
should have called it
actually i like functional filmmaking
it's really clean yeah classy
uh yeah here's another topic uh so
i don't know if you guys have seen the
emails today uh well some of you don't
get these emails because
we don't want to bore you guys with
these but
we've gotten like eight submissions
today for
some video lightsaber effects on ticket
talks
i've been getting spammed on twitter and
instagram about it too
so okay i looked up this account guys
you know
i've i've ranted about this in the past
and i'll rant about it again in the
future and i'm gonna rant about it right
now
ready what is with these people okay
there's a there's a ticktacker
uh account it's not even an account it's
like a username
and then it just has a number after it
and this account
all day today we've been getting people
hitting us up being like hey
uh these guys are stealing your stuff uh
so oh yeah
what these a-holes did these jedi
a-holes
is they they took uh they took uh
the world's longest lightsaber and they
put it behind a sponsored
video where you can get audio effects uh
for 29.99 and they're using our video
to sell that now i went to the account
wait what i
the one i saw was selling a lightsaber
right
so this is on the same channel
so they took uh i don't this is clearly
some kind of bot
spam sort of like computer
account because there's about
there's about 50 60 70 videos on this
account
but all of them are just the two
episodes one is
a dude with a lightsaber and he's
fighting his buddies in a parking lot
which is also they ripped off
from somebody else and then the other
one is
uh is the world's longest lightsaber
video
and literally every post is just that
and there's just those two videos just
those two sorry there's a third one of a
guy unboxing a lightsaber
that was the one i saw yeah uh so
there's those only those three videos
are being posted on this account
and it and it looks like it's just
started today
from what i can tell um wow and there's
uh
there's over 70 posts of just these
three videos multiple times
each one having you know different view
counts
and like i i just don't get it
you know like at what at what point
what's there not to get okay here we go
like like like what what
what is tick tock doing do these guys
care at all
do they care at all like what protocols
are you implementing into your platform
to prevent people from doing this
like this person's clearly and not only
that but they're now paying
you to have their videos display
like in front of other people's videos
that are being watched on tick tock like
you have no protocols for this
and then they're like questioning and
then they come out
you know when when the government when
the federal government was like hey
we're going to shut down tick tock and
people were like oh hey wait hold on
tick tock's got integrity
hold on we got integrity here wait
hold on a second and look you know and
it's just
it's just like this is a prime example
this is a prime example and i know it's
an extreme example
but it's ridiculous and this is going on
all the time and it's going
on to to hundreds of creators who are
making videos
and they're just straight up being
ripped off and used for advertising i
mean ren you've gone through this
we've gone through this it's just man no
it happens on facebook too though think
of the children to get it done
they're like taken down okay so yeah so
just so you know
i've tried to take down things on tick
tock and there's literally no response
like literally of course not they have
it right right it's another country that
runs that program they have uh they have
so they have a tick tock copyright like
report form
and uh you fill it out like facebook's
actually pretty good about it despite
the fact that facebook
side tangent pretends that they can't do
anything about it
and then and then you know takes it down
after the fact after you manually
manually ask them to take it down even
though for some reason i don't know it's
weird
youtube somehow came up with a system
for it i don't know i don't know how
they did it
they must be geniuses everyone at
facebook must not be
that's all i can discern or
or they just actually make a ton of
money from the ads being spent before
the videos get taken down
and so they have no incentive to do
otherwise maybe that's
that's me and then they just tell the
federal government in their
congressional hearings that there's
nothing that they could do about it
and because the senators don't
understand how facebook works
they just go ah okay sounds like he's
being honest yeah
companies like facebook aren't
incentivized to like you know
patrol or you know police that sort of
thing is the same
same thing with youtube back in the day
back in the day the only reason why
youtube changed is because they were in
a
huge lawsuit with
[Music]
and that was like a huge lawsuit and it
changed a lot of the ways that youtube
was fundamentally run
facebook and tech talk have never had
those reckonings you know it's like
totally and it's a good example of like
the of the necessity of that type of
action
within the system but still like
you would think at this point you know
it's not like like when youtube had that
lawsuit both youtube and facebook came
out at pretty much the same time it was
like 2005
2006 and and obviously youtube had the
problem
and viacom went after him and facebook
didn't have
video at that point they just had
pictures and profiles
and uh but you know that was that was
16 years ago 15 years ago like
they've been at it you know they they
they have
they have a 30 of all digital
advertising being spent on their
platform
you would think like okay come on you
know
they can they could make a content id
yes in the effort
they have a vr company and the ftc
should step in and and the fcc should
actually be regulating these but that's
a whole other thing that i won't get
into
so anyways tick tock guys i understand
you know you were a startup you were
just trying to get people to watch your
videos
but like if you're gonna if you're gonna
last
you know this is something something
must be done think of the children
remember the tick tock children think
about it didn't tick tock
used to be musically all the memes were
that music
yeah and then they were bought and yeah
they went throughout the whole
rebrand and stuff but um
man it's it's remarkable so i'll try to
take it down again but the last time i
filled out the tick tock
copyright report form there was
literally
no response it was just it just like
went into the ether
tick tock ate it and turned it into a to
a video game
jake if we're going on tick-tock rants i
got another one for you
first of all i didn't explore tick-tock
until very recently because i
i have some ideas of like parodying
tick-tock and making an account that's
completely
just to [ __ ] on it basically um
but i i dove deep into the world of the
memes of tiktok and
the big problem with it is there's so
little regulation
on miners doing things that like they
should not be doing
on the internet yeah like there's no
like
there's so little like that's done about
it yeah and not to mention
some [ __ ] that i've seen i i was
watching like oh my god that like
do they not the [ __ ] about any sort of
you know age restriction stuff on this
and they don't
the fundamental problem is exactly that
is that it's it's
it's not it's a chinese-owned company so
they they are not participating with the
rest of you know
the the western world to be like okay
like we're going to establish
x y and z protections for people under
these ages and we're going to sign these
generic treaties that say
hey in general we're all going to agree
to this they're not they don't they're
not
doing that and so yeah and so it's just
like
it's like a free world over there and i
don't think i i don't think that's like
res
obviously i i don't think that's not
resonating with the people
that are obviously making the most
popular videos on the platform they're
they're like look hey
i'm i'm 16. i this is the first
social media profile i've ever had it's
got hundred thousand
followers don't yeah don't take it don't
want me in peace
yeah exactly don't take a dump on me i'm
having friends i'm having fun with my
friends
and just let me be and i understand that
desire but like there's also a world out
there
that has consequences and if we just go
about it like this
and we let stuff like this happen i just
yeah it's honestly dangerous yeah it's
super dangerous long term in the long
term
and i'm not just trying to get on get on
a soapbox here i'm just saying like
this something needs to be done about
this it's very clear
yeah so anyways um we just lost niko
now your video's gone yeah just a little
a little stick man
yeah so thanks for staying with me
through that guys
um happy to do it super excited about
son of a dungeon
uh sam and i have already been bouncing
around a ton of ideas
and uh real quick just to interrupt you
back back on the tick tock thing oh
i don't care about it anymore but
because we've made videos about
people stealing our content every single
time
someone sees it they take a screenshot
and they message me so i get hundreds of
messages
i know like hey i saw your video on tick
tock and i'm like
i know i can't do anything about it
and it's just like an odd slash so
please stop letting me know
how else do we find out okay maybe
here's what we should do
tell the corridor twitter account not me
okay here's yeah
so so maybe maybe going forward
to so that ren doesn't have a have a
twitter breakdown
because of all this comments and
submissions
we come up with a an email slash
like account and then we tell people
like
it's like reports that court or digital
or something and we just tell people to
use that
you know some sort of handle or specific
email to target people towards
because i do really appreciate it when
people let us know about stuff like this
uh yeah but i mean yes
it's just that like they think they're
doing me such a favor by messaging me
and telling me about this
that they seem really uh offended
whenever i just kind of like ignore it
oh well you can't expect i wouldn't
expect you to respond
well you have are you going to go
through every single response and like
just respond to all of them right now
like you're doing just that'll work
this was that response yeah there you go
there you go all right so ren's cleared
the air and would anyone else like to
clear the air about anything in their
life at this point i mean we've lost
niko
we've lost visual on nico i don't know
what happened and audio now oh no no no
i'm here i'm here
he's there yeah this is probably a good
spot to wrap it up because i still have
to finish my color grade for tactical
reloads
okay so yeah yeah
yeah i'm just happy to be here again
madison is happy to be here all right
cool that was fun
um thanks for thanks for playing and uh
look for tactical reloads to come up
with some money next weekend
and uh look for the show on corridor
digital.com at some point
yeah so there you have it signing off
signing off uh this is uh the banjo boys
and uh that's broadcast we can't leave
until we get that sweet sweet banjo
oh i gotta go now
he's out
[Music]
goodbye everyone
goodbye goodbye